I'm going to talk about a failed
supernova explosion which has resulted
in a
weird white dwarf heading out into the
depths of space
okay so a paper came out on the 20th of
june
so relatively recently here it is sdss
and then the long telephone number that
tells you what the star is
the partially burned remnant of a low
mass white dwarf that underwent
thermonuclear ignition question mark so
I think we need to back up a little bit
and talk about so this is a white dwarf
star
and it's associated with a particular
type of supernova
uh thing called a type 1a supernova very
famous type of supernova because it's
used as a standard candle something
which is the same brightness wherever
you see it
so it's used for cosmology where we can
actually use it and figure out how far
things are away from how bright it
appears
the reason why it's a standard candle is
because of the mode
the way in which it explodes and
essentially what happens is you have a
white dwarf
which is a very compact star it's held
up only by the pressure of
quantum mechanics effectively the always
the question with the star is why it
doesn't just collapse under its own
gravity when it's
burning nuclear processes in its core
that provides the energy source that
keeps it up
but the end of its life that goes away
and the star will collapse
and so for example for a white dwarf
it'll collapse right down to something
about the size of the earth
at that point these weird quantum
mechanical effects kick in and stop it
collapsing any further but what can then
happen
there is a maximum mass for which that
effect will work
thing called the chandrasekhar mass and
if you keep adding
in some way more and more mass to the
start eventually you're going to
approach that mass
and there's a danger that the thing will
collapse further
and actually all sorts of turmoil will
occur within the white dwarf star it'll
become very convective it'll become very
disturbed inside
that's the point at which white dwarf is
in danger of actually exploding
by firing off a whole bunch of new
nuclear
thermonuclear processes but in a very
uncontrolled way
and so it will essentially explode like
a bomb
interestingly the the views on this have
changed it used to be thought that when
a star tipped over
that magical chandrasekhar mass that was
the point at which it blew up
as a supernova it's now thought it never
quite gets to that mass but as it
approaches that mass as i say it becomes
very disturbed
stirs up very energetic processes can
start happening and something
then kicks off these uh nuclear
explosions within it so then the
question is
what why would a star be putting on
weight where's its extra mass coming
from
and in order for that to happen there
has to be another star nearby
to kind of donate the extra mass and so
it's probably in systems where there's a
binary you've got two
two stars orbiting each other and one of
them is donating
some of its mass to the white dwarf and
so eventually it reaches to this point
where
these runaway nuclear processes occur
and it explodes
so sort of skimming matter from its
next-door neighbor it's sufficiently
close to it it's actually ripping the
mass off it it's you know it's
its pull of gravity becomes stronger
than the pull of gravity in the star
that was holding onto that matter to
start with
so it's literally ripping off the outer
layers of its of its neighboring star
and acquiring them for itself usually
that process
is thought to be sufficiently disruptive
that there's nothing left at the end
that the star just literally blows
itself to bits
the interesting case here is that here
there is still a white dwarf left
but it has some weird properties and in
particular when they studied the spectra
of it
when they split the light up into the
colours of the rainbow and looked at
the sort of signature of the different
different chemical elements
they found some of those heavier
elements that are made in the supernova
explosions
so it looks like some sort of
thermonuclear process has occurred with
this white dwarf
but it clearly hasn't been quite as
destructive as it usually is because
there's still a white dwarf left at the
end
and the other interesting thing is that
the nuclear processes haven't gone all
the way
to the sort of end state that they
usually do usually you end up
producing you know so the the carbon in
the white dwarf
ends up producing silicon and silicon
turns into nickel and the nickel turns
into iron
there's a whole series of nuclear
reactions that go on and those produce
all the elements up to iron the
interesting thing about
this white dwarf is it doesn't have
those heaviest elements in it it doesn't
have iron in it it doesn't have nickel
in it
so it looks like the process was sort of
incomplete
it didn't destroy the star and it didn't
go through all the nuclear reactions
that these things usually go through
so it's like a failed supernova it
didn't quite fail clearly something
pretty dramatic happened to it
but it didn't quite go all the way so
it's sort of yeah it didn't quite
detonate completely it was an incomplete
detonation the other interesting thing
about
it this particular star is they can
measure its speed you can measure the
doppler shift to tell you it's speed
along the line of sight but actually
there are also proper motion
measurements for it they're also
measurements of its
its changing position on the sky so they
know how fast it's going
and it's actually it's going around the
wrong way it's not orbiting around the
milky way in the same direction as most
stars are
and on top of that it's going at about
200 kilometers per second so it's click
it's going along at a pretty rapid rate
which suggests that whatever the
explosion process
was gave it a pretty big kick so it's
now traveling at high speed
this again is a sign of something to do
with probably the fact that it was in a
binary system to start with
it'd be nice to think that you know it
was just some failed explosion that
kicked it enormously but it turns out
that that probably isn't enough to give
it the speed that we see
but what is enough to give it the speed
we see is if it was in a binary system
and the explosion was sufficient to
unbind the binary so that
the two binary stars were no longer
bound to each other because if for
example this was a white dwarf that was
orbiting another white dwarf they can
get very close together which means
they're actually traveling around each
other
at hundreds of kilometers per second and
so if you then suddenly take one of
these white dwarves away the remaining
one will then just keep traveling at
that
several hundred kilometers per second so
it looks like it was probably in a very
tight binary probably with another white
dwarf star
this incomplete explosion occurred
because it
ripped enough of the material from the
other white dwarf to create
a partial explosion and that disrupted
the
the second star probably almost
completely and so this first star then
shot out uh into the milky way but the
one that's shot out is the one that
underwent the supernova of sorts yes
yeah the other one was probably it might
have been destroyed completely in the
explosion just because it
got caught in the blast or it might
still exist it might itself
also be flying off in some other
direction um there's really no way of
telling so we haven't we don't know
where the other like the brother is
no clue at all so the one that's firing
off
that we do know about the one that's
firing off into the depths of space
it's not just the recoil from the
explosion it's to do with the kind of
uncoupling from the gravitational
interaction exactly it's almost
certainly to do with the fact that
what we most of the speed we're seeing
is the speed that it originally had in
its binary system but suddenly that
binary doesn't exist as a binary anymore
so it's just flying out into space
so there's a couple of interesting
implications of this one is that this
type of explosion so the reason why we
typically see supernovae
isn't because of the original explosion
it's because those explosions produce
lots of radioactive material which then
subsequently decays and over the weeks
and months that follow
we see the energy that's being released
from those
nuclear decay products the main nuclear
decay product in type 1a supernovae is
nickel
and of course this one never got around
to making any nickel so it wouldn't have
had any
material to go through this decay
process which means that if we had been
around when the supernova occurred it
probably almost certainly worked it
would have been in the very distant past
but if such supernovae do go off you
probably wouldn't see them
because unless you happen to be looking
at just the right moment when the flash
occurred
then you wouldn't see it and then there
isn't that then slow subsequent decay
that would allow you to catch the
explosion
later on the second sort of slight
warning here is this
you know the the simple story we usually
tell about type 1a supernovae is they're
all the same and it's very
straightforward and that's why we can
use them as standard candles
there is at least a little bit of a
warning here that says actually
sometimes weird things happen
and you get incomplete explosions or
different kinds of explosions
so it doesn't mean we have to be a
little careful if we're going to be
using type 1a supernovae as standard
candles
mike you refer to this remnant that's
barreling through the milky way
as a star is it still acting like a star
is it is it undergoing nuclear processes
and emitting light and
i mean it's still emitting light because
it's still hot but it's a it is
it's still a white dwarf star so it's
still held up by its degeneracy pressure
it's not got any new nuclear processes
going on in it
so it's a question whether you count
white dwarfs or stars or not if you
think a white dwarf is a star then this
thing's still a star if you think it's
just the remnant of a star then i guess
at this point it's just the remnant of
the star
mike if this is a common process and
this happens a lot
would we have seen them before now like
should we consider this an oddity or is
it possible these things are everywhere
i mean they are relatively faint so
maybe we don't
find you know we don't find all of them
necessarily and maybe we haven't studied
all stars in sufficient detail but i
think
what this is probably telling us is this
this is a kind of a rare process and if
the story i've told you is right
that it originated in a pair of white
dwarves that was sufficiently close to
each other that one was actually ripping
material from the other
and at some point one of them underwent
a kind of slightly failed explosion
it's probably a fairly unlikely scenario
so i suspect there's probably not a huge
number of them out there but we
really don't know at this point it
sounds quite exciting though doesn't it
the idea of this
of a white dwarf like you know barreling
through the milky way on this sort of
cannonball run and sort of running from
the scene of the crime as well actually
right
it's clearly you know that it's just
survived this massive explosion and is
now heading off as fast as it can
did this finding excite you like do
these things still surprise you
absolutely in fact so you know so in
fact you told me about this paper i
didn't know about this paper at least
you pointed me towards a newspaper
article about it
uh which got me to read the paper uh
it's not why you know i usually do
galaxies i don't do white dwarfs and
supernovae and things but
the more i read about in the paper the
more interesting i got in it because
it's clear this is a very intriguing
object
star clusters or if they were galaxies
and if there are galaxies then that's
something really really interesting
because it's not clear how such a
dense galaxy could form which is really
really quite nice it's not a very
impressive image
but this is the first image that new
horizons took before it went on to take
images of jupiter when it flew past
jupiter and then images of pluto
and now even images of an asteroid in
the kuiper belt as well